Tras quizá un año trascurrido, nada.
Un día se le acerca un señor
que le ofrece llevarlo a almorzar,
después a cenar, a desayunar.
Conoce a un dinámico grupo de personas,
que le da un descanso.
Recibe un poco de dinero
para que se compre ropa nueva,
dinero para enviar a casa, a su familia.
Le presentan a una joven.
Finalmente se casa.
Comienza una nueva vida.
Tiene un objetivo de vida.
Un hermoso día en Mogadishu,
bajo un cielo azul,
estalla un coche bomba.
Ese niño de aquel pequeño pueblo con sueños de la gran cuidad
era el terrorista suicida,
y ese grupo dinámico de personas
eran al Shabaad, una organización terrorista
conectada con al Qaeda.
Entonces, ¿cómo la historia de un niño de un pequeño pueblo
tratando de cumplir sus sueños en la ciudad
termina con él inmolándose?
Él estaba esperando.
Estaba esperando una oportunidad,
esperando comenzar su futuro,
esperando una perspectiva de futuro,
y esto fue lo primero que le llegó.
Esto fue lo primero que lo sacó
de lo que llamamos "el periodo de espera".
Y su historia se repite
en centros urbanos alrededor del mundo.
Es la historia de los marginados,
jóvenes urbanos desempleados
que desencadenan disturbios en Johannesburgo,
desencadenan disturbios en Londres,
que buscan algo mas allá del "periodo de espera".
Para los jóvenes, la promesa de la ciudad,
el gran sueño de la ciudad es el de la oportunidad,
de trabajos, de bienestar,
pero los jóvenes no participan en la prosperidad de sus ciudades.
A menudo es la juventud la que sufre de las más altas tasas de desempleo.
Para el 2030, tres de cada cinco personas que viven en las ciudades
serán menores de 18 años.
Si no incluimos a los jóvenes
en el crecimiento de nuestras ciudades,
si no les brindamos oportunidades,
la historia del "periodo de espera",
la puerta de acceso al terrorismo, a la violencia, a las pandillas,
será la historia de las ciudades 2.0.
Y en mi ciudad de nacimiento, Mogadishu,
el 70% de los jóvenes está desempleado.
el 70% no trabaja,
no va a la escuela.
No hacen prácticamente nada.
Volví a Mogadishu el mes pasado,
y fui a visitar el Hospital Madina,
el hospital donde nací.
Recuerdo estar ante ese hospital
acribillado a balazos pensando:
¿Y si nunca me hubiera ido?
¿Y si me hubiese visto forzado
a estar en ese mismo "periodo de espera"?
¿Me habría convertido en terrorista?
No estoy realmente seguro de la respuesta.
La razón por la que estuve en Mogadishu ese mes
era en realidad para albergar
a unos líderes juveniles en una cumbre empresarial.
Reuní a unos 90 líderes juveniles somalíes.
Nos sentamos y tuvimos una lluvia de ideas sobre las soluciones
a los grandes desafíos que enfrenta la ciudad.
Uno de los jóvenes en la habitación era Aden.
Él fue a la Universidad de Mogadishu, se graduó.
No había trabajo, ni oportunidades.
Recuerdo cuando él me dijo,
que debido a que era un universitario graduado,
desempleado, frustrado,
era el blanco perfecto para Al Shabaab
y otras organizaciones terroristas, para ser reclutado.
Buscaban gente como él.
Pero esta historia toma un camino diferente.
En Mogadishu, el mayor obstáculo
para llegar del punto A al B son las calles.
Veintitrés años de guerra civil
han destruido completamente el sistema vial,
y una motocicleta puede ser la manera más fácil
de movilizarse.
Aden vio una oportunidad y la aprovechó.
Comenzó una empresa de motocicletas.
Comenzó alquilando motocicletas
a los residentes locales quienes normalmente no podían comprarlas.
Compró 10 motos, con la ayuda
de su familia y amigos,
y su sueño es en algún momento expandir
a cientos de motos durante los próximos tres años.
¿Por qué es diferente esta historia?
¿Qué hace a esta historia diferente?
Creo que su capacidad de identificar
y aprovechar una nueva oportunidad.
Es el espíritu empresarial,
y creo que el espíritu empresarial puede ser
la herramienta más poderosa contra el "periodo de espera".
Faculta a los jóvenes
a ser los creadores de las oportunidades económicas
que están buscando tan desesperadamente.
Y Uds. pueden entrenar a los jóvenes para ser emprendedores.
Quiero hablarles acerca de un hombre joven
que asistió a una de mis reuniones,
Mohamed Mohamoud, un florista.
Estaba ayudándome a entrenar a algunos de los jóvenes
en la cumbre de la iniciativa empresarial
y cómo ser innovador
y cómo crear una cultura de la iniciativa empresarial.
De hecho, es el primer florista que Mogadishu ha visto
en más de 22 años,
y hasta hace poco, hasta que Mohamed llegó,
si querías flores para tu boda,
utilizabas ramos de plástico
enviados desde el extranjero.
Si le preguntabas a alguien,
"¿Cuándo fue la última vez que viste flores frescas?"
para aquellos que crecieron durante la guerra civil,
la respuesta sería: "Nunca".
Entonces, Mohamed vio una oportunidad.
Comenzó una empresa de paisajismo y diseño floral.
Creó una granja en las afueras de Mogadishu,
y comenzó a cultivar tulipanes y lirios,
que según dijo, podrían sobrevivir
el duro clima de Mogadishu.
Y comenzó la entrega de flores para bodas,
creando jardines en las casas,
y las empresas de la ciudad,
y ahora está trabajando en la creación
del primer parque público de Mogadishu en 22 años.
No hay parques públicos en Mogadishu.
Quiere crear un espacio donde las familias,
los jóvenes, pueden ir juntos,
y, como él dice, oler las rosas proverbiales.
Por cierto, él no cultiva rosas
porque utilizan mucha agua.
Así que, el primer paso es inspirar a los jóvenes,
y en esa sala, la presencia de Mohamed
tuvo un impacto realmente profundo en los jóvenes.
Ellos nunca habían pensado en iniciar un negocio.
Habían pensado en trabajar para una ONG,
trabajar para el gobierno,
pero su historia, su innovación,
realmente tuvo un fuerte impacto sobre ellos.
Los obligó a mirar a su ciudad
como un lugar de oportunidades.
Los alentó a creer que podrían ser empresarios,
que podrían ser artífices del cambio.
Para el final del día, ya tenían
soluciones innovadoras
para algunos de los mayores desafíos que enfrenta la ciudad.
Idearon soluciones empresariales
para problemas locales.
Entonces, inspirar a los jóvenes
y crear una cultura de espíritu empresarial
es realmente un gran paso,
pero los jóvenes necesitan capital
para hacer sus ideas realidad.
Necesitan experiencia y orientación
para guiarlos en el desarrollo y puesta en marcha de sus negocios.
Conecten a los jóvenes con los recursos que necesitan,
bríndenles el apoyo que necesitan para pasar de la concepción a la creación,
y crearán catalizadores para el crecimiento urbano.
Para mí, el espíritu empresarial es algo más que
comenzar un negocio.
Es crear un impacto social.
Mohamed no está simplemente vendiendo flores.
Creo que está vendiendo esperanza.
Su Parque de la Paz, así es cómo lo llama,
cuando esté creado, transformará
la manera en que la gente ve su ciudad.
Aden contrató niños de la calle para ayudar a alquilar
y a mantener las motos para él.
Les dio la oportunidad de escapar
de la parálisis del "periodo de espera".
Estos jóvenes empresarios están teniendo
un tremendo impacto en sus ciudades.
Así que mi sugerencia es:
conviertan a los jóvenes en empresarios,
incuben y alimenten su innovación inherente,
y tendrán más historias sobre flores y Parques de la Paz
que autos-bomba y "periodos de espera".
Gracias.
(Aplausos)